you remember back to August and the
atrocities the media told us about not
in Mexico or Brazil certainly not in
Ukraine but at Mar-A-Lago remember that
classified documents were discovered
illicit classified documents including
top secret cocktail napkins at
mar-a-laga there was even and we're
quoting the Federal indictment a
birthday dinner menu found somewhere
near the first lady's closet now the
Washington Post first reported that the
nuclear codes or relevant nuclear
materials secret ones were discovered
there and that's why a former CIA
director and Michael besch lost the
historian suggested it could be time for
Donald Trump to be executed by electric
chair
and for sure and this was the consensus
in Washington once these documents were
discovered this crime
was Unearthed there was no possibility
Donald Trump could ever again run for
office he needed to go to jail
every person connected to Biden
Administration told us that including
Joe Biden himself what data was there in
there that made compromise sources and
methods Biden asked
so as Biden was saying that it turns out
that he was and you'll be shocked to
hear this doing exactly the same thing
that he accused Donald Trump of doing
Joe Biden was throwing classified
documents in a private office at a fake
think tank that has been set up for him
at the University of Pennsylvania that
thank fake think tank is called the Penn
Biden Center for diplomacy and Global
engagement at the University of
Pennsylvania
now we should tell you we don't know
exactly what these classified documents
are and unlike Michael beschlas and the
former head of the ca we're not going to
speculate but according to CNN they were
very sensitive quote the classified
materials included some top secret files
with the sensitive compartmented
information designation also known as
SCI which is used for highly sensitive
information obtained from intelligent
sources
so what exactly were these materials
were they the nuclear codes we're
probably going to find out pretty soon
because there's no question Merrick
Garland will unleash one of his
signature pre-dawn raids on the
University of Pennsylvania at any moment
because it's a national security threat
American will get right on that but
actually Penn may be a national security
event we know you're very impressed your
nephew got in but Penn as an institution
takes an awful lot of money from the
Chinese Communist party not making that
up in recent years Penn has received
more than 50 million dollars from
Anonymous Chinese donors so the question
is were those donors peering at the
classified documents the National
Security secrets that Joe Biden had been
stashing at the fake think tank that
Penn set up for him how much access did
they have exactly to these documents
we're very much looking forward to the
Washington Post expose on that subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight